pearl-white vivacious a pleasingly natural
actress pearl white was a symbol of her
times a woman struggled for political and
social equality in the early 1900s instead
of just demanding equality with the men
pearls showed that she was their equal and
more at a time when movie heroines were coy and
helpless her wife was dashing and self-reliant
Earl White's first serial and still the most
famous of them all was the Perils of Pauline
made in 1914 the Indians believed pearl to be a
long-awaited goddess if she survives the ordeal
of the Rockland for immortality will be proven
if not then her sacrifice will appease the gods
with the first world war in progress pearls
enemies became spies and saboteurs here in
1917 in a serial titled girl of the army she's on
the trail of the master foreign agent known only
as the silent menace we commented earlier
on pearl as a symbol of woman's fight for
equality over and over as if to emphasize this
she'd take on the male villains single-handed
and continued it was chapter after
chapter with pearl ever close on
the heels of the silent Menace once in
a rare while miss white would exercise
her feminine prerogative the being womanly
she'd let herself be rescued by the giro
is the unmasking finally at hand hardly this
was still only Chapter five and the audience
was way ahead of pearl in figuring out that this
was only a red herring and not the silent Menace
just before 1919 miss white gave up cliff-hanging
to star in full-length society drummers
but in her last feature made in Paris she
came back to the kind of role her fans like
best even the title signified a return to
the pearl-white of old the perils of Paris
none of pearl cereals were made in Hollywood
for her backgrounds she used the steel wild
landscapes and mushrooming towns of New Jersey
in New York this film plunder in 1923 brought
to a close the career of the greatest
of all the serial Queens the plot was
about buried treasure but all that really
mattered was pearls brand of fast action
plunder is one of the rarest of all
the pearl white serials this episode
was copied from the only known surviving print
quicksand
one chance in a thousand Perle bowed out at
movies while she was still on top leaving her
work as a yardstick for all who came after before
pearl white there were other serial queens the
very first in 1912 was Mary fuller who's what
happened to Mary series was produced by Thomas
Alva Edison's own movie studios Helen Holmes
have the hazards of Helen railroading was her
specialty in every episode she was in action on
and very often nearly under a speeding locomotive
then came Helen Gibson the airplane was
in its infancy then and the automobile
and locomotive still represented the ultimate in
speed and power standard equipment
in a hundred different serial plies
the villains have weakened a trust me helen
has to get there in time to prevent the wreck
but of all the serial queens
who followed pearl-white only
the beautiful ruth roland was a serious rival
Ruth Rowland specialized in outdoor adventure
and daredevil stunts the cereal is Ruth of
the Rockies and Miss Rowland has little choice
between two consistent enemies fire and water
and so it went week after week but as the
serial smashed their way into the 20s the ladies
relinquished much of their dominance women's votes
and other rights were now accomplished and as if
in keeping with social progress the serial queens
were now content to do their cliff-hanging under
the protection of a much more authoritative male
hero other changes reflected the march of events
tempos were fastest the heroes like Herbert
Rawlinson here were breezier and more dapper
the high cliffs of the mountains were pikers
compared to the man-made chasms of the big cities
ten years had gone by but the password
was still continued next week serials
were box office and meant big money in
the 20s and a lot of big name starred
in them Jack Dempsey gene Tunney Red
Grange and the greatest escape artist
the world has ever known master of
mystery and illusion Harry Houdini
run cereal high spot saw Houdini
suspended over a vat of flesh-eating acid
anyone coming to his aid through this door
would unwittingly plunge into a horrible death
serials like the grown-up fairytales
that they were made use of another
basic ingredient horror it was usually
concentrated in the form of a sinister
hooded mystery villain guessing his identity
was part of the fun of silent serial going
mechanical monsters under control of arch
beams where another Saturday afternoon delight
many of the cereals were brilliant in
their handling of impossible situation
but when a cereal was made quickly
and without imagination the results
could be surprisingly crude this cereal is
typical here is the Frog sinister ruler of
a vast empire of crime bent on controlling
a scientific formula with which he can rule
the world a fake doctor's office serves
as a cover-up for the frogs headquarters
the heroin Liva gerber is kidnapped
knowing that the police are on his
trail the frog camouflages his hideout
judging from the lack of logic the script seemed
to be written only a shooting progressed however
cereal fans were remarkably loyal and
even though an aging Ben Wilson as the
hero officer 444 was approaching the end of the
trail as a cereal star his youthful fans still
applauded this somewhat unconvincing
battle but the Frog is still at large